hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts high-content imaging and
analysis for drug discovery phenotypic
assays instrumentation and software
I am Marjorie Torrez of lab boots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
reeds and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific Thermo Fisher Scientific
incorporation is the world leader in
serving science with revenues of 18
billion dollars in more than 65,000
employees globally their mission is to
enable their customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer they help
their customers accelerate life sciences
research for complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity
through their premier brands thermal
Scientific applied Biosystems
Invitrogen Fisher Scientific and unity
lab services they offer a none much
unmatched combination of innovative
technologies purchasing convenience and
comprehensive support for more
information please visit w-w-w
thus webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge your flights window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problems through
the green Q&A button lower left this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
CD button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Nicholas Dolman
Nicholas Dolman is the senior staff
scientist and research and development
Biosciences
a thermo Fisher Scientific dr. Doleman
received his PhD from the department of
physiology at the University of
Liverpool and completed a postdoctoral
fellowship at the NIH dr. Doleman has
been with thermo Fisher Scientific for
seven years he has lots of development
of over 50 products that cover a disease
range of technology diverse range of
technology platforms including
fluorescent protein based biosensors
Invitrogen quick IT chemistry and
environmentally sensitive dyes I will
now turn it over to dr. Nicholas Dolman
for his presentation Thank You Marjorie
and thank you all for joining us today
for this webinar
where we'll go through high content
screening and its uses in Life Sciences
Research
so today and the presentations will just
start off little bit by looking at some
of the advantages of high content
imaging and analysis will also look at
what you need to actually perform the
acids what are the components that will
allow you to perform a successful assay
we'll talk a little bit about the
readouts what are some of the biologies
that you can easily address and we'll
touch on some of our bio applications
contained in the studio software will
also look at models we traditionally
think of high content imaging and
analysis as being for cell based assays
but I'll show you data with its
application as we move forward into
different models as well and then
finally we'll just touch on some
real-world applications we'll look at
the use of high content screening in
cell health to give yourselves a little
bit of a sort of health check how are
they doing
are they alive or dead what are some of
the site's protective mechanisms that
may have been activated well look at a
face for proliferation as well using our
novel clinic technology we'll look at
the application of high content
screening and actually making cell
models here we'll look at the use of
stem cells to make neurons to model
diseases we'll also look at high content
screening and antibody drug conjugates
as well how can we use this innovative
approach to assess how effective a
certain ADC maybe we'll also look at
profiling when we've carried out a
CRISPR genome editing ourselves how can
we use high content imaging and analysis
and the broader range of reagents
available from thermo Fisher to find out
what happened to yourselves
following a CRISPR edit and then finally
we'll also look at some screening
applications where we've looked at a
large s RNA library from some very
distal site cellular readouts so what
are the advantages of high content
screening well there are a number of
them but let's remember the high content
screening is no different from standard
for essence microscopy you're you're
still using a similar sort of optical
path however with high content we
actually automate both the acquisition
on the front end as well as the analysis
on the back end so we're still taking
fluorescence images okay we're still
using the same readouts the familiar to
the standard microscopy user however
we're using the software today
automate and acquire images objectively
we're not as the user picking which self
that will be sampled then of course
because the analysis is also automated
we can go through and very easily and
analyze the lot ourselves we're talking
millions of cells within these plates
and how this does it is all within our
algorithms contained in the studio
software we're able to identify cells
often this will be nuclear staining will
segment off the nuclei so dye such as
Daffy or Hertz two three three four two
commonly used there are other mechanisms
to segment cells of course we can use
wholesale State some of our HTS masks or
indeed cell tracker dyes for life all
applications this allows the software to
identify cells as it's acquiring and
then this is the basis for all the
subsequent downstream analysis once we
know where a cell is we can start to
look for properties within the cell here
we see a field of Dappy labeled nuclei
and in green here this is clicking
eating you with alexa fluor 488 we know
these cells are proliferating the
software is able to pick that up we're
sampling a huge number of cells and we
can plot any number of features that the
software automatically acquired and
start to look for patterns we can look
to gate on certain populations we can
say any cell with an intensity above or
below a certain value we see as a
percent responder or not we can start to
gave me plot them look at them and
because of the properties of the imaging
we're actually able to then correlate
the data the numerical values with
actual imagery you can click on any cell
in the analysis software any data points
and bring up an image of the cell that's
incredibly important for inline QC make
sure your assay is segmenting properly
so what you're reading out really is
true when you're not picking up
artifacts list all all of our data comes
through on the fly for analysis as you
run let's just give you a quick example
an application very close to my heart
this is Otto Fuji and so what one would
do coming into the bile application
software is to click on the auto for ESA
icon this gives you preset settings for
this a see here we're using a lung
cancer cell line a five four nine cell
we're going to label the nuclei with a
cell permeable DNA dye Hertz
three twenty three four two following
drug treatment we're
you going to fix ourselves an immuno
label with the Monti body against lc3 be
the gold standard for all to phagosome
this is a very commonly used marker to
show the presence or indeed absence of
Auto phagosome within the cells so then
will detect that with a secondary
antibody of course using our premiere
alexa fluor 488 die so in these fields
within the world were labeling
themselves with hooks now we're able to
pick up the nuclei our software will and
say how many nuclei we have in a field
and we can ask the software to acquire a
certain number of cells and we generally
do around about a thousand per condition
we then take an image in the second
channel so standard microscopy approach
here we're picking up the signal from
the alexa fluor 488 which is reporting
the presence or absence of auto
phagosome this is in the maximum drug
treatments that we're seeing an awful
lot of auto phagosome is present we then
build a ring this is our cytoplasmic
area here we've chosen just to take a
relatively small region around the
nuclei that's then overlaid onto the
image of the lc3 bee and from there we
ask the software to identify spots so
this is an automated spot counting
algorithm we can see here in the top
this is the the minimal treatment
vehicle to see very few spots the bottom
is the maximum which I showed you
previously and you can instantly see the
difference in the number of spots if you
were doing traditional master essence
microscopy you would either have to
count these manually or import them into
third-party software or our packages do
this automatically this is a dose
response curve this is seven
concentrations of the vacuolar a EPA's
inhibitor battle of Mycenae one it
alkalized is lysosomes inhibiting
autophagy flux and so we see
accumulation our horse Packers ohms put
in within the cell there are a number of
different readouts that we can take and
this is incredibly important to remember
here we can look at rings fault
counts the number of spots present in
their cytoplasmic ring we can also look
at the area and indeed the intensity of
the lc3 be staining and these aren't
criteria that we pre-selected this all
comes through automatically as you're
actually able to mine your datasets look
for novel changing parameters it's a
very useful tool to to interrogate novel
biology so what we're doing here we have
replicates of six with seven
concentrations of the drug we're
plotting the means from each well this
is a very nice way of getting
reproducible and robust data but what
we're also able to do is actually mine
and pull the data from every single cell
within these wells I'm just going to
show you how we do this for ringspot
area here this is the data for the
ringspot area from every single cell
within all of those wells
there's several files themselves and
this is a really important aspect of
cell biology that high-content imaging
is able to address mainly the
heterogeneity within a population so do
not respond as one they show
differential responses you can still see
that those dependent increase in the
ringspot area when we plot the data from
every single cell and however you can
see that even at lower concentrations
some are responding and having a fair
ringspot area and at the highest
concentrations about one micromolar we
can still see some cells that aren't
responding very much at all so again
this is the the heterogeneity that's
spread
respondent we can also present it as box
plots this is the 25th and 75th
percentile responders and so there's all
sorts of different ways that you can
then take that data and represent it to
really show a heterogeneous response
this is just some examples from our data
using motofuji I'd also point you to
this paper in the literature from Lance
Taylors laboratory here they show and
describe and server analysis and an
acquisition protocol to look at there is
heterogeneity within cell population and
in this published example they look at
phosphorylated stat3
and show some beautiful examples of how
cells show differential responses to
reference compounds
so what do we need to carry out the
successful hike on Tennessee
well there are a number of things that
you will need to have in place to get
this sort of data the first is your
label so for example our reagents from
thermo Fisher Scientific these will
allow you to label cells and pick up a
number of different responses
everything from apoptosis to aw topper G
mitochondrial health and so on you'll
also need the hardware so these are
things like RHCs instrumentation and we
offer a range of solutions from our
bench top cell insights CX life right
through to our newly developed cell
insight cx-7 the cell inside cx-7 has
inbuilt a confocal capabilities allowing
you to optically section through a fixed
sample as well as laser autofocus to
complement our standard image based
autofocus and then of course we've had
our flagship product the array scan
which is also compatible with confocal
acquisition as well as liquid handling
and then finally not the instruments in
the reagents themselves are nothing
without thereby Upland software this is
our newly developed HTS Studio 3 that
contains newly updated file applications
and all the analysis software to
automate these highly complex
fluorescence athletes and make them
really very simple to perform
so when we start to look at how these
translate into life sciences research we
should look at some of the outputs a
very simple application is translocation
here we show an example of nuclear to
cytoplasmic transportation using NF
kappa-b we're able to look at the
intensity in that ring region represents
representing the cytoplasm as well as
the nuclei and here you can see the
software segmenting the cells we take
the nuclei again to tell us where we
have a cell we then use that to bring
out and build out the picture of the
cytoplasm as well as the nucleus and
here the compound is tnf-alpha
we can see that robust translocation
each of these color traces represents
the data from one row in a plate so this
the replicas of six across a ten-point
dose response curve of tnf-alpha
we can look at other readouts not just
intensity within regions we can segment
very fine fact structures such as
elements of the cytoskeleton
microtubules or the actin microfilaments
and here we have the example where cells
have been labeled with alexa fluorine
488 for lloyd 'n we can treat the midi
bruh high dose 10 micromolar of cycle 8
indeed to disrupt the actin
microfilaments or a much lower dose
which doesn't have an appreciable effect
on those microtubule the software has
been able to identify the microfilaments
segments them we can pull off a number
of fiber properties in green we can look
at the number of 5 accounts - how many
fibers within a cellar actually picked
up we can also look at intensity in red
you can see the intensity increases and
that's evident from those images what we
see is as sight oklet's indy disrupts
those microfilaments they condensed down
to points within a cell which label very
intensely
I showed you examples previously with
otology an lc3 beaver these same spot
algorithms can be applied for other
features so for example here we're
looking at the interaction between a
ligand EGF and its receptor here we have
a gfp stable solo expressing EGF GFP
we've labeled the cells again with hugs
to delineate the nuclei now we're using
a flurry Genet EGF ligand that Frodo is
a pH sensitive dye that is essentially
non fluorescent in neutral environments
only when this dive internalised into
endosomes and subsequently traffic to
the lysosome do you see this dye light
up so when attached to EGF we can do
these assays and in no wash formulation
so we conveyed the cells in EGF we won't
see any signal from outside only the EGF
being internalized we're going to
modulate the internalization in this
assay using an inhibitor of
clathrin-coated mediated endocytosis the
compound called pitstop two at low
concentrations we can see that there are
spots forming within the cells of the
positive for Frodo ready EGF if we use
higher concentrations of pitstop a very
short pulse of 30 minutes we can see
complete inhibition of the
internalization of both the receptor as
well as the ligand eg a again we can
plot this as a dose-dependent readout
here we see the dose dependent decrease
in receptor internalization a mirrored
by a dose dependent inhibition of ligand
internalization as well finally another
example where rather than using
intensity to look at translocation we're
just looking at the intensity within a
specific compartment reading out a
biological response here DNA damage
using an antibody against the DNA damage
marker phosphorylated h2x the treating
cells with the top aside and looking for
the in single intensity from this
antibody you can see as we go up in
concentration we see a dose-dependent
increase in the intensity of our
antibody labeling and these are just a
snapshot of all the different biologies
that can be read out and we'll show you
a few more as we go on through the
presentation so what about models well I
alluded to this earlier I content her
imaging and analysis isn't just for your
cell based assays
can be applied up to 3d structures as
well as model organisms a very useful
tool is the use of 3d thyroids here we
have a kidney furrowed label with a
confocal unit on the cell inside cx-7 we
can see active and and high fidelity
segmentation in nuclei within this 3d
thyroid and because we're able to
optically section with our confocal
capabilities and build a 3d
representation of these cards
we're able to do more complex I see this
is a Heelys thyroid we're using our live
dead assing live cells are green dead
cells are red and you can see the
increase in the number of dead cells as
reported by the red indicator when we
switch from vehicle to a cytotoxic agent
the claws might in a 3d culture we can
also look at other more physiological
functions here is an MC f7 tumour
steroid we've labeled with hurst again
to tell us the number of cells have been
destroyed now we've labeled them with
our newly developed hypoxia reagent the
images hypoxia grow this central light
supple gives rise to fluorescence when
it's in environments or reduced oxygen
or hypoxic conditions so here we're able
to image the hypoxic or within a tumour
steroid and of course much like our
confocal capabilities enable thyroid
research they also help in another thick
tissue or samples here we have an embryo
a body we're taking a maximum projection
of 20 slices comparing the performance
with confocal on the right versus white
field when we look at the ante beta 3
tubulin staining of this embryos body we
can also image tissue here's a kidney
tissue using some alexa fluor 488 wheat
germ of gluten you can see the
improvement in resolution with our cell
inside cx-7 confocal versus wide field
and finally we can apply this to complex
model organisms here is an image and
overlaid the segmentation of a zebrafish
this is manju Genesis model using the
zebrafish as an organism to study
angiogenesis and now we can look at some
vessel properties obviously highly
important to angiogenesis and its study
we can look at the vessel count and
vessel length as a function of
whereas concentrations of two compounds
so we're able to apply high content
imaging and analysis not just from cell
through to steroid to tissue and into
model organisms we have data and other
model organisms as well things like C
elegans and the like so let's take a
look at some applications in real-world
examples and I'll just list those out
for you to first start well we'll take a
look at cell health so we can think of
the hell the health of a cell as a
continuum they can go from healthy to
signs it all is not well sort of a sign
that the cell is unhealthy we can also
look at sighted protective mechanisms
these are activated to take the cell
back from not being particularly healthy
back to a well state we can then look at
markers at the point of no return after
which the cells cannot recover and they
progress the die as we look at the
induction of cell death we can look at
the mechanisms such as apoptosis we can
also read out whether or not the sellers
day we're also developing tools to look
at some of the consequences that clean
up as it were how do cells of the immune
system deal with dead cells and
translate these into cell based assays
the health of the cell is incredibly
important it's an often studied area
because really as researchers we often
fall into one of two categories
we're either interested in trying to
keep cells alive so if we work in post
mitotic cell types such as neurons or
cardiac myocyte these can't be replaced
and so it's incredibly important to try
and promote their survival of course if
we work in oncology or cancer or on the
opposite end of the spectrum we're
looking to drive cells to die who are
looking at indicators themselves are
dead really almost everybody in basic
research field falls into one of two
camps so we spend an awful lot of our
resource of developing assays and
showcasing the use with high content to
read out these various portions there
are really a number of different ways in
which you can look at any one number of
these points viability can be really any
function of normal physiological actions
within the cell these are some of the
hallmark ones that we look for
controlled protein synthesis and RNA
synthesis polarized mitochondria which
will produce ATP
they also won't be giving out our OS / -
we'll have a predominantly reducing
cytoplasmic environment as well
regulated proliferation some of those
signs at all if not well or pre lethal
indicators have a canary in the coalmine
as it were a loss of protein quality
control depolarized or depolarizing
mitochondria an oxygen oxidizing
cytoplasmic environment which is often
underscored by the production of our OS
birth lower ATP concentrations within
the cytoplasm as well as deep
deregulated proliferation when we start
to think of some decided protective
mechanisms we're thinking about things
such as Auto Fuji or DNA repair when we
think of mechanisms and cell there we're
talking about that pop ptosis or
necrosis or it's programmed form
necroptosis an inviability almost always
we looks at the loss of the plasma
membrane integrity and then we can read
out some of these in immunological
consequences by looking at a face for
phagocytosis to find which will report
these finally eat me signal as well as
various aspects of the inflammatory
response themes such as these danger
associated molecular patterns which
signal whether or not an inflammatory
response will be initiated today just
for reasons if time I'm just going to
show you a few of our probes their
application and high content for these
three areas loss of membrane integrity
caspase-3 seven activation as well as
polarized mitochondria so as I said
before one of the most common ways of
looking at viability is through plasma
membrane integrity we can actually add
an additional level of reporting here by
looking at enzyme activity living cells
will often have certain key enzymes
active and so by labeling them with
reporters of this enzyme activity we can
report not just death but as well as
live cells well typically use a green
dye such as caffeine AMS report the live
cell and will use an impermeable plaque
acid binding dye these can enter the
cells and so green cells will show up a
third live cells will show up green they
will not have any residents upon
induction of cell death we see a loss of
plasma membrane integrity which means
that the green dye is no longer retained
it leaks out you lose the green signal
and you gain a red signal this is what
it looks like when we treat cells with a
low dose of cytotoxic age
just enough to kill a few of the self
will see a mixed population of live
cells in green and dead cells in red we
can read this out with high content
imaging in that analysis using intensity
or percent responders here's an
intensity readout we're looking at the
intensity for both the green and the red
signal we see a drop in the green signal
with a concurrent increase in the red
signal as a function of increasing
cancer teasing concentrations counter
Thiessen being of course highly
cytotoxic agent which will very
effectively kill cells we can learn also
look at the mechanisms which are selling
voice to activate cell death here we're
going to look at the activation of
caspase 3 7 caspase-3 7 is activated
both both for the intrinsic and the
extrinsic pathway so it's a good readout
for general apoptosis we have a fluoro
genic reporter sullivan caspase-3 7 and
we can see when compared to untreated
cells cells treated with toxified share
a significant increase in the intensity
of this label and indeed this this
change it's not not looking at intensity
but percent responders
so we say we ask the software to gate
with over a certain intensity value
we'll say that they are a poor topic now
we look at an increase in the number of
cells undergoing apoptosis as a function
of compound treatment here stars born
abroad acting kinase inhibitor which
indeed induces apoptosis we see a
dose-dependent
increase in the signal from this
reporter it is specific for apoptosis
and we can keep apoptosis of the tonic
level with a low dose of saris board and
apply increasing concentrations of the
caspase-3 seven inhibitor we see a
dose-dependent loss of the signal
reflecting its specificity to caspase-3
7 we can also back this up with genetic
models here's a CRISPR cast 9 model
where we've knocked out castes 9 and we
can see no signal in the café's 9
knockout with increasing concentrations
of stars born yet we see a
dose-dependent increase in the matched
parental line and of course caspase-9 is
just upstream of calf age 37
sister it's a very nice specific
modulator of caspase-3 seven activity
there are a lot of ways are looking at
mitochondrial function specifically
mitochondrial membrane potential here
I'm just going to showcase one of our
agents TMR em or tetramethyl rhodamine
methyl ester the potentiometric probe
that accumulates within my polarized
mitochondria we can see that it is truly
mitochondrial and it overlaps with our
background cell light my toe GFP so we
are getting very good mitochondrial
loading we can look at the intensity
from these mitochondria as a function of
protons for concentration so proton for
such as cccd would depolarize
mitochondria here's a high content assay
looking at one hour after compound
addition in three different cell lines
these replicates and six hours
themselves the condition so you can see
here we're doing a very very high number
of cells across a number of cell lines
we're able to do it very very rapidly
and efficiently of course we can
multiplex these reagents and start to
look at the sequential induction of
apoptosis so here we can look at the
loss of mitochondrial membrane potential
and subsequent activation of caspases
for apoptosis using PM RM and cell
eventpro together you can then build
this with step further by using some of
our mitochondrial morphology probes such
as The MITRE tracker probe here we use
micro tracker deep red TMR em sell em
Bank a speed three seven and of course
took two segments themself now we're
able to look at mitochondrial
fragmentation the loss of the membrane
potential and subsequent activation of
caspases
so assays for proliferation are very
very popular we've developed a clique of
edu assay so this is a brdu table RC
rather than looking at the incorporate
corporation of brdu when sales are in S
phase we use a different time it in
analog here a final D uridine it's
clicked compatible so we can do this
very nice file orthogonal chemistry to
link a reporter as either modified alexa
fluor died on to that edu so sell the
fed edu if they're proliferating they
will incorporate them into the nuclei
within fix and Fermi ablaze carry out
the click reaction and now we're able to
very precisely label them this is a
culture of human dermal fibroblasts we
Sutor colored the Alexa 488 click Aditi
you in orange the total number of nuclei
are in purple and then the micro tubules
in science and you can see that within
this 3d culture of human skin cells we
can see quite a few cells are actively
proliferating as reported by the
incorporation of edu during this short
30 minute pulse we can also look look at
this users tool to look at them changes
in proliferation here we're using RNAi
eye to knock out a molecular motor
involved in mitotic exit if we knock
this motor down and wait for 48 hours
and then do a short pulse of edu we see
the cells are next to ping mitosis
because of the loss of kinesin 11
they're not free to then enter S phase
so you see a reduction in the edu
incorporation with population of cells
so very nice tool for looking with
modulation and proliferation not just
genetically but also chemically here we
have a dose response but the commonly
used mitotic inhibits attack so and we
see a very nice dose dependent
inhibition of edu incorporation in this
assay so easy is very useful for looking
at proliferation but it can actually
tell you other aspects of cell biology
we can combine it with DNA to look at
DNA content antibodies against specific
markers of the cell cycle so here we're
using
Dappy for DNA content tell us the to n
and foreign population we can use these
S phase marker to tell us which cells
are an essay and then here we're using
phosphorylated histone 3 as a g2 n
marker
we can build these almost flow cytometry
like lots of cell cycle progression we
can start to say which cells are in g1
which are in s phase which are in g2
which true which are potentially blocked
in g1 s and again we're sampling a large
number of cells we're getting very
robust and reliable data sets we can
also use proliferation as a very
sensitive marker of pre lethal toxicity
so this time we're going to pair an
impermeable nucleic acid dye image at
dead green with our clickity bul EXO 647
RP we're using the Fed C and sci-fi
channel so live cells will have a
certain level of proliferation that's
reported by red nuclei but they won't
have any report from the green dye
because they haven't died if a cell was
to die the green dye would gain access
of course once felt dead it's not
proliferating so we won't incorporate
edu we can actually use that to look at
changes of the curve before death is
even induced here we're using a very
high concentration of camptothecin at a
very very short pulse only a few minutes
why you can see is that there really
isn't a large induction of death that's
reported by a dead green however what we
see is a very prominent shutdown of FA
the cell cycle the cells have sent
something's wrong they haven't died yet
but the loss of proliferative index in
the cell population is the indicator
that all is not well so it's another way
in which we can look for pre lethal
toxicity the multi parametric fashion
using spatial readouts amenable to high
context screening and I will actually
use a high content imaging and analysis
to set up some biological models going
to look at neuronal differentiation here
we have a model from our colleagues in
Gimpo words that the production of
dopaminergic neurons from stem cells
starting with these human pluripotent
stem cells the kit actually allows you
to differentiate into the floor
progenitor or fpp cells which are the
intermediate step before production of
mature dopaminergic neurons these are an
excellent model for various human
diseases that can be studied the basic
research
we actually have a very robust workflow
that allows you to reduce these mature
neurons within about three three or so
weeks and of course high content imaging
analysis is a very useful tool to deploy
alongside this protocol what we can do
is we can look for markers that the
slope rate progenitor cells have been
formed so the presence of fox a tune and
altitude tell us that we have the story
progenitors we come in and use that
segmentation and targeting servation
module to tell us that we have these
molecules present that way we can
segment say how many of our human
corporate and stem cells have
transferred into this intermediate state
from there we then mature them into
mature dopaminergic neurons and using th
which is tyrosine hydroxylase is a
marker of mature dopaminergic neurons
we're able to read out how successful
this protocol is we can segment look for
the presence or absence of this marker
count the number of nuclei count the
number of cell bodies shown positive for
tyrosine hydroxylase from their
calculator how many of these cells are
positive and are indeed transformed into
mature dopaminergic neurons the core
high content screening doesn't have to
stop there we can actually look at more
detailed neuronal properties for example
synaptogenesis so what we do here we are
still employing a nucleic acid stain
Dappy here we're then going to label
those neurons with a neuro marker map to
then using antibodies against both pre
and postsynaptic structures some after
fighting for presynaptic regions and PhD
95 post up to density 95 the post
synaptic marker were able to look at
synaptic synaptogenesis our software is
able to segment the nuclei from their
build up a picture the cell body once
the cell body has been identified then
the projections the axons in the
dendrites
can be segmented from that we can
overlay
spot analysis at those pre and post
synaptic markers and quantify how many
synapse is are present within this
neuronal population we can quantify that
indeed look at the effect of adding
certain compounds okay
completely which will modify and
modulate glutamate receptors so here
we're just looking at the number of pre
and post synaptic vesicles from that
reading out the number of synapses but
we can also look at other properties of
these neurons that may correlate with
the compound treatment we can look at
the number of neurons and neurons we can
look at the intensity of staining their
total length we new branch point
analysis neurite width so there's a lot
of different aspects of your biology
that come through automatically and then
can be mined we can also use this same
advanced segmentation of neuronal cells
to look at toxicity so if we look at
stimulation of control cells with ngf
into more mature neurons and then
subsequent cell death a face for example
with cytotoxic compounds such as
retinoic acid we can look at segmenting
their the neurons as a readout of how
healthy they may be we can look at the
number of cells and you're like
branching the number of neurons as well
as their length as you start to plot how
these various features change as a
function of compound treatment we can
also assess the effectiveness of an
antibody drug conjugates so antibody
drug conjugates will bind to a cell
surface receptor they'll often be
internalized traffic to the lysosome
there the lytic enzymes activated
compound they then diffuse out of the
lysosome by permeations and act on their
cytoplasmic target we're going to show
you a sort of complete assay here here
we've labeled a therapeutic antibody
accepting using our new site click
chemistry this is a site specific and
defined conjugation approach here we are
able to label them and just look at the
uptake of these antibodies so we're
using SK be ourselves and mbm MD am b23
ones FK be ourselves are her to positive
so Herceptin is able to bind MBA cells a
her to negative so Herceptin won't bind
we can use an unrelated therapeutic
antibody receiver relative of Rituxan
which won't bind to her too what you can
see from this trace we're just looking
at the membrane intensity
using high context imaging and analysis
you can see we see a significantly
larger signal from the SD bow which is
our click chemistry method of labeling
these antibodies with Herceptin and in
no other situation do we see that signal
so there's no signal when we labeled as
Iver using click chemistry on her to
sells her t+ skv ourselves of course we
see no signal from either designer or
Herceptin in her2 negative
MDA and b-cells they're not only a
suspect in binding specifically but
these therapeutic antibodies aren't able
to be just taken up by a spirit fades
into psychosis we can look at the time
and dose response here so these are skb
ourselves and her to positive we can
label them for 29 hours or nine hours or
five hours and look at both the time and
dose dependency of the uptake as well we
can then modulate this this quick
labeling approach and actually add on
the toxin as well as a reporter so here
we label the antibody not only with a
reporter Alexis 647 but also with a
toxin in this case it's MMA e in
microtubule inhibitor these Deep Ellum
arises microtubule triggers mitotic
arrest which then subsequently causes
the induction of apoptosis we use our
model as I described previously of SK
BRC at 3 cells for her to positive as
well as the her2 negative MDA line you
can see there's no signal from the alexa
647 in the MDA cell we do see a very
bright and robust signal for the FK be
ours
we can look at the uptake of alexa 647
into these SK be ourselves and then we
can also overlay that in the same cells
in a multiplex experiment with the
induction of apoptosis using sullivan
caspase-3 7 the course we can look in
the her2 negative MDA cells we see not
only as a no uptake there's also no
induction of death
let's look at some screening
applications we're just going to show
you an example of an fi RNA library here
we used a small focused library against
the Chi gnomes with all the kinase in
the genome we use cytoskeletal analysis
as a distal point there looking at how
these kinase is across the spectrum may
affect cytoskeletal structure we were
looking not only their fact in other
detail before but also microtubules will
also use some of our cell as a whole
cell stains that cell masks the look at
cell and nuclear morphology to see if
they're changing software segments these
cells is able to identify both actin
microfilaments as well as microtubules
and from there form a high-throughput
quantitative analysis we're able to look
at 52 cellular properties simultaneously
across the treatment of various kinase
if not down the pepperoni we can cluster
them based on conserved responses across
those 52 parameters we can cluster them
rule basically will visualize them along
a 2 main component analysis vaccine and
start to group them have a look for how
these genes may fall into conserve
signaling pathways across the board we
can actually look at the which-which
kinase is fall into which clusters so
finally I'll just end up and show you an
example of using high content imaging
and analysis in combination with thermo
Fisher fluorescent reagents to perform
phenotypic profiling of Krista Castile
edited cells so why do we do that well
obviously CRISPR casts 9 is a very
popular system it's been in the news a
lot recently and it's a lot of
researchers are looking to incorporate
this this workflow into their research
when you perform a CRISPR cast 9 edit
one of the confirmation experiments
you'll do is maybe sequence them to
confirm that you've performed the
knockout successfully you may also do
GCD a say so genomic cleavage detection
so this will also confirm that you've
got specific nucleons activity at the
loci of interest of course whenever
you're knocking out a gene doesn't have
to be with Christopher cast 9 it could
also be with RNA I it's critically
important to check that the protein is
gone
because if your protein has an extremely
long half-life these two references here
discuss some of the importance of
protein half-life itself it doesn't
matter if you've lost the gene because
the protein will still be there to act
but we're going to show you why it's so
important to also do complimentary cell
based assays because although you may
have lost the protein the can be
occasions where other proteins can
compensate and kick in so now you're
actually able to confirm the phenotype
that you'd expect with that genotype I'm
just going to show you a very quick
example to start with further phenotypic
Athey here we're looking at knockout
using CRISPR caste 9 of GC LM the
glutamate received like lion I gave my
OC it's involved in the synthesis of
reduced glutathione and reduced
glutathione is one of the main
cytoplasmic buffering mechanisms to
protect cells against reactive oxygen
species induction we blot using an
antibody against gtlm and we can see
that we've lost the protein so what are
the functional consequences we've not
the Gina and these genes have been
sequenced as well at least we can
concern the genes being lost as how's
the protein but now we can deploy a
proximal a thing so very close to the
gene of interest this is file tracker
violet it's a direct measure in cells at
the amount of reduced lucifier and we
can indeed see that the knockout cells
show significantly reduced glutathione
levels so here our cellular assay a
phenotypic assing has complimented our
proteomic and genomic I think these are
very important to do when you're
knocking out a gene can make sure that
your cells are displaying the right
phenotype we can take it a step further
we can actually use cell based assays
and functional athletes to construct a
complete picture of cellular function to
look at the consequences of CRISPR
Cassadine editing we can combine as
close to the gene as well as far away to
both proximal and distal assays and I'm
just going to use that example of
autocracy again otology is a complex
multi-step process one of the most
commonly deleted genes is ATG five is
involved in the conjugation of lc3 to
the auto phagosome or membrane without a
tg5 lc3 be cannot be conjugated to
fostered head and are left alone
we won't associate with autosomal
membrane and the cells are deficient in
macro Auto Fuji here we have a cast 9
stable cell we've transfected these
cells using our neon
electroporation system with guide rnas
against ATG site when compared to the
parental or scramble transaction the ATG
5 9 at the ATG 5 trans vector file share
significant loss of lc3 beefsquatch
intensity as a function of chloroquine
chloroquine acts in the similar manner
to battle my theme to blackboard
associate flux
these are pooled cells so not all of
them have successful knockout if we then
go and take this pool and select clones
we can block and show that 80 g5 was
lost in these 5 clones we then pick a
clone clone 3 review subsequent analysis
here actually using co-localization
analysis one thing that you'll see when
you block or to face your luck is flux
is the co localization of lv 3 B 4 or
tobacco zone with lysosomal markers and
here we're using an antibody against
lamp 1 and lysosome arrest and enzyme
you can see in the parental line in red
we see increasing co-localization of
these two markers as a function of
chloroquine concentration whereas in the
knockout line clone 3 of the ATT 5
knockouts we see no overlap we see no
formation of LC 3 b+ puncta this cell is
deficient in the formation of autogas
ohms it won't be able to carry out macro
Auto Fuji
so we've confirmed with a proximal assay
that indeed the the cells display the
phenotype that would be indicated by
both the proteomic and genomic studies
we can then take it a step further and
start to look at related processes P 62
or FQ stm-1 is a receptor for targeted
or tofu gene it recognizes ubiquitinated
cargo and binds to that cargo it also
binds to a c3b thus bringing that cargo
into the auto phagosome we can look at
the number of spots in the wild-type
Kyle the parental line versus the
knockout what we see is as expected the
number of p60 to positive spots
increases when we block autophagy flux
in the parental line
however the knockout line shows a
similar increase in the number of spots
and actually also subsequently
creases when we treat with chloroquine
this is what we'd expect the knock out
line are unable to carry out macros
offer G and so will won't be able to
clear P 62 however is intriguing to see
true Punk performing we weren't really
expecting that so we could start to look
at where they are we can block and show
that are indeed increased levels of P 62
within these cells however these Punk's
are aren't getting into the lysosome
because in life cells using our
background primero Tophet EGF B P 62 we
see that they don't overlap with the
lysosomal marker lies attract a deep red
chloroquine treated wild-type cells
those P 62 thumbs up do overlap the
lines attract a deep reds shown that
they've been correctly traffic to the
lysosome they just can't then be
degraded however in the ATG 5 knock out
that Punk to do not co-localize with the
lysosome indicating that they're
accumulating within the cytoplasm which
should be consistent with the elevated
levels of P 62 in these knockout cells
so the consult Afridi's are primarily a
pro survival mechanisms it helps cells
to withstand periods of nutrient
deprivation it clears damaged organelles
as well as helping to deal with invading
microorganisms and circled zeniff ages
we wanted how healthy these met these
cells were during our cell culture will
assess liability with our counter cell
culture cell counter and we actually
noticed there's no difference in
viability so maybe those cells are still
alive or perhaps they were teetering on
the edge and we're ready to die at the
slightest threat well to do that we
looked in the induction of apoptosis the
same model as I showed you before this
is using sullivan caspase-3 7 and
sparrows boring to do tautology and we
see no significant difference in the
induction of otology between the
parental line and the ATG 5 knockout so
not only are these cells healthy and
culture they're also not predisposed to
cell death by the induction of apoptosis
however staris born and canadian
abyssion may not typically target or Tov
a G so we wanted to start to look at
maybe more like an auto 4G related
processes so we looked at their fusion
so because all factors on fuse with the
lysosome we started look at some of the
consequences of a DG 5 knockout with the
lysosome we used a number of different
tools to lysosomal demarcation so we use
an t lamp 2 and we saw no difference
significant difference in the number of
lamp positive vesicles between the
parental and the knock out line when we
did live a safe easing like the track of
their lives in Madrid quick compound we
actually saw a significant increase in
the number of only the area of these
live attracts lies attract a positive
spot suggesting some dysfunction in
lysosomal properties between the eighty
g5 knockouts and parental line even
though they don't seem to be any
difference in the number there is
something different in terms of their
functional properties we then use the
second orthogonal readout of lysosomal
activity this is a thirty pfl
fluorescent conjugates to the drug pep
statin a statin a inhibits cathepsin
vine strikes of conception so we can use
it to read out except selectivity with
themselves and we see a significant
increase in the 30 PFF had statin
labeling in the knockouts and compared
to the parental cell shown these cells
do have significantly altered lysosomal
properties because autophagy is involved
in organelle homeostasis we're intrigued
to see what happened to two other like
an organelle function here we used might
attract orange to look at mitochondrial
properties and we saw there was actually
a decrease in the number of mitochondria
in the knockout compared to the parental
cell life however when we looked at the
area occupied by the mitochondria labels
is actually significantly higher
suggesting some dysfunction in the
balance between fission and fusion of
mitochondria in the ATG v marker we
could also look at functional properties
so although both pools are mitochondria
in the knockout and the wild-type were
able to be depolarized by CCCP it
appeared that a significantly higher
polarized state of these mitochondria
they showed increase TM RM intensity in
the knockout compared to parental line
again suggesting some difference in
mitochondrial function we actually took
this a step further and started to look
at other organelles we could look at the
area occupied by a golgi label this is
using anti Golgi in 97 we see no
significant difference in the area
occupied by Golgi labels within the cell
we do however see a significant
reduction in the area occupied by the
endoplasmic reticulum here we use a
marker against fossa Dyess fossa die die
after I saw Marine PDI we
a significant reduction in the ER area
of the knockout sounds we'll also see
some perturbation of actin cytoskeleton
function we see slightly higher numbers
of fibers within act the ATG v knockout
versus parental and finally we are able
to look at peroxisomal
biology so peroxisomes like a
specifically cleared by a process known
as excitation and in these knockout
cells we see a significant reduction in
the area occupied by anti TMP 70
labeling peroxisomal membrane protein
for using high content screening we're
actually able to look at not only
processes close to the gene of interest
a PG 5 a tautology or its clearance of
its receptors start to probe some of the
more distal and potentially unrelated
processes we're actually seeing are
affected by reducted by knockout of this
gene so things like organelle Maps
organelle function so again we just
highlight there the broad number of uses
of high content screening in the life
sciences research and with that I will
finish up for today I hope you found
today's webinar useful we will be taking
some questions we may not have time to
get round to all of them right now but
if we don't we'll be following up after
the event so thank you very much
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question-and-answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them and the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window but I don't
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is talk how accurate
are these technique using 3d tuner model
are tested for spirits or also for the
Hydra based model can you talk a little
bit more about how high content imaging
is being used today to look at organoids
and 3d models for example what
measurement systems or markers are they
using so yeah that's a very good
question not only do you need the
optical systems that are able to do
image within these these steroids things
like a very very robust light sources
from the LEDs plus the confocal
capabilities for detection you also need
to validate the reagents make sure
they're permeating all the way into this
four so we are actively working on
validating a number of our reagents in
these models looking at ways in which we
can improve our mobility
reduce nonspecific binding as well thank
you and our next question is we often
find the center of micro tissue dark
grid control codes is this is this due
to the opacity or due to the students
not penetrating into the center of the
tissue it's almost certainly a
combination of both of those so you have
you could be having an issue of the
light getting in to excite the
fluorophores the light then exiting
you're not being scattered as well as
the penetration are of the probe
the next question is what kind of codon
plates for a neutron culture sorry could
you repeat that like I miss lost it what
kind of coding plates for nutrient
culture I don't have any experience in
that that area but what we could do is
is actually follow up offline on that we
can put you in touch with some of our
our plate
ping house sass or quickly can a single
fluorescence image be acquired for a
typical imaging application it will vary
from application to application I
generally don't have acquisition times
longer than 100 milliseconds I would say
typically from about 10 to 100
milliseconds for your standard
fluorescent reagents and secondary
antibodies of course the Hoechst
labeling is even lower often a
millisecond or two every now and again
you may have to go a little bit higher
than 100 milliseconds especially if
you're using a very dim reporter but
generally speaking about about 10 to 100
milliseconds ok it looks like we have
time for one more question
how long are the exposure time yeah so
it's similar to that last question I'm
relatively speaking about 10 to 100
milliseconds is what we aim for it's
rarely you need to go higher every now
and again you will but almost all of
those images you see there on the low
side of that around about 50
milliseconds or so and of course the
exposure time will affect your your
total acquisition time for a plate so
again we always try and get very robust
and also not only bright it's stable
light sources and you know when your
light source fluctuating in power
because that can give you false
differences in the intensity readout
and the last question is high content
screening is a relative new addition to
the drug discovery process can you
comment on how you have seen customer
use HTS in a drug discovery campaign as
well as comment and some of the common
hurdles or challenges people are running
into yeah I mean we've seen high content
really deployed across the spectrum of
drug discovery not only from the
standard screening of libraries of
compounds from pet to lead campaigns but
also in discovery biology and pathway
analysis so you can actually start to
look and interrogate there the
biological cat signaling cascades that
might be targeted in a therapeutic
campaign as well as once you have your
target in mind actually screening
whether or not the compounds are working
so it's really deployed across the board
as well as in toxicity profiling once a
compound is a little server on and again
I for any questions we haven't been able
to answer we will get back to you and
answer those so we apologize if we
weren't able to answer your questions
because of time but rest assured we will
follow up with you
thank you dr. Doleman for your
presentation I would also like to thank
our sponsors their my Fisher Scientific
for making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
December 2017 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you on this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time and
goodbye